dans sa lettre charles pasqua rappelle
qu'il avait soutenu inconditionnellement
à jacques chirac lors de la création du
rpr mais aussi lors des présidentielles
de 81 et 88
récit d'une amitié de trente ans avec
carrollton pasqua chirac
l'histoire est ancienne première
rencontre dans les années 70 ce
rapprochement lors de la création du rpr
en 76 amitié enfin après la première
campagne présidentielle de jacques
chirac en 81
les français eux découvrent charles
pasqua en 86 avec la première
cohabitation il devient ministre de
l'intérieur dans le gouvernement de
jacques chirac qui apprécient ses
services rendus
sa fidélité ex et son sens de
l'organisation charles pasqua figure
centrale de la campagne présidentielle
de 88 qui se soldera par l'échec
vient ensuite le temps des divergences
90 et la tentative de putsch du tandem
pasqua séguin dirigée contre les
dirigeants du rpr jacques chirac et
edouard balladur 92 et la campagne du
référendum de maastricht 93 enfin où
malgré les efforts de charles pasqua
jacques chirac refusera de retourner à
matignon pour laisser la place à edouard
balladur pasqua balladur tout les sépare
depuis toujours mais charles pasqua
retrouve le ministère de l'intérieur et
une nouvelle popularité
j'ai pas arrêté le mot c'est un petit
matelas comme dirait monsieur bart de
français qu'ils m'accordent quelques
confiance moment venu s'il le faut
j'utiliserai sur crédit afin que les
français se rassemblent derrière celui
qui incarnera assauts montbarla les
principes auxquels nous sommes attachés
après avoir longtemps fait mine
d'hésiter charles pasqua vient donc
officiellement de trancher en faveur
d'edouard balladur
la rupture avec jacques chirac est
aujourd'hui consommé l'ancien président
du rpr doit désormais se sentir bien
seul